there's no cohesive or structure here
that's a big problem in the military as
well the reason you're seeing all these
incompetent uh ineffectual General
officers is because of careerism they're
more interested in promoting their own
career than they are giving feedback
that might get them a negative response
that's what I'm being told from that
yeah so these Chiefs of Staff are like
they don't want to go or these shoes
with these Joint Chiefs or whatever they
don't want to get fired they don't get
demoted right well it's hard it's it's
beyond yeah he can he they serve the
pleasure of the president he can remove
and replace them whatever he wants uh
but it's it's beyond that
what happened with James Mattis who was
a darling of the American Military for a
while I mean service members loved this
guy for a while and uh then he was part
of this
what was it uh uh the 700 generals
General officers and Former Intelligence
people that wrote a letter against
Donald Trump supporting Joe Biden for
the election he was one of those guys
that did that and
um about a month afterwards he got hired
to the board of General Dynamics right
you know I mean that's it's weird so
it's it's well beyond just
the it's well beyond just the careers
and it's what that career turns into
afterwards Lloyd Austin
worked for a company right
and
that company was bidding on a
multi-billion dollar contract and the US
government had said that they're
probably not going to get it it doesn't
look good for them we're going to go
with the other guy and he becomes the
Secretary of Defense and I think about a
month later
or three months later that his his
former company gets that contract this
is weird so it's not just I get what
you're saying about removing all these
politicians but it that is the that is
the very top layer right of scum if you
want to call it well yeah so so I would
I would I would go into this and say we
have we have a structural Decay across
the board correct yeah when people are
willing to vote for no reason other than
tribe to earn points or because they
believe some garbage nonsense right or
in this instance you've got you know
people aren't reporting crimes because
what's the point I've been I've been in
the situation I'm sure you guys have as
well where it's like I had I had one
incident where uh me I was driving with
my brother and we got hit by a cab and
the cops were like you know okay we'll
we'll file all this but you guys are
going to show up right like you'll show
up to court if we do this right yeah
because they have to show up regardless
of you doing now yep and we were like
like okay let's do this and it's easy to
say at the time and then what happens a
month goes by and they're like okay
here's the date and time you got to show
up and I'm like dude I got I got work
yeah like I can't just sometimes years
man right if it's a yeah it's a serious
enough crime sometimes years go by if
they have a good enough attorney
sometimes yours go by so we've we've got
structural to create Decay across the
board in in every facet and so yeah
maybe it's fair to say just simply
recalling you know Newsome isn't enough
it's it's good I definitely think you
know getting a year of some someone else
in there is a good thing but you know
you're talking about the military I've
heard I've gotten emails we've heard a
ton of stories people resigning someone
sent me a resignation letter recently
someone apparently you know wasn't was
an officer and announced like over the
over over just the wokeness CRT and the
vax Mandate they're like I am quitting
and it's actually sad really because
I've heard these stories of people who
are like it was my dream to be you know
in to have a career in the military work
there until retirement and now it's like
I'm in my mid-30s and I'm out I'm done
can't do it right somebody some people
even giving up like their pensions which
it's super sad too because who's going
to fight this next War it's not going to
be these guys we saw in Afghanistan this
past a couple of weeks right
work needed to get done and I have no
lack of faith in the 82nd Airborne guys
who were there or the Marines that were
there I'm sure I have no doubt that
there are plenty capable of doing that
job but because of the leadership there
they weren't allowed to do that right so
I wonder uh who's gonna fight the next
one and we we saw we saw the answer it
was guys like Tim Kennedy and these and
these other guys uh that went over there
on their own dime right guys that are
well Tim still in but everybody but him
was already out of the military they had
served their country they were done and
they spent their own money to go back to
conduct these operations not to go kill
people or blow things up they went over
there to save people right that's what
the American war fighter does they are
they are and it it troubles me that the
the ranks of the US service member have
now been infected with this nonsense oh
yeah because I don't know like you were
talking about police earlier I'm not
sure how much
you can trust the individual at this
point you know what I mean it's getting
bad this this female staff sergeant that
posted a video like you know when people
are coming door to door that's going to
be me and I'll shoot you or whatever
like yep first of all you never held a
gun in your life and it's pretty obvious
but
that's a that's a she that's who they
want this Lieutenant Colonel gets booted
out of his position and then he resigns
this woman I don't know what's happened
to her have you heard any news about her
nothing
that seems like somebody that should be
immediately kicked out of the military
they want Storm Troopers they don't they
don't want rational thinking individuals
who are going to say like here's the
Constitution here's what might you know
you've got an officer that publicly said
she was gonna storm people's doors she
was a non-commissioned officer staff
sergeant E6 yeah well she didn't say she
was going to she said when it starts or
whatever she said I don't want to
paraphrase too much but she she
basically said the people going door to
door that's going to be me and I I will
that's terrible that's a form of Terror
she was like what do you think's gonna
happen when we're ordered to you know to
point you down it's not gonna it's gonna
be us and we're gonna do it instead
she's well what she says you refuse the
command
you know I I firmly believe and have
believed for a very long time that if
ordered most probably enlisted would do
it would absolutely shoot an American no
joke well we've seen it before right
Kent State it's it's happened in in our
parents lifetime 1970 May 4th I went to
Kent State for college they fired on the
crowd the national guard fired on the
crowd killed four college kids yep one
guy took a bullet through his own
through his hand no but uh so I've I've
you know been around military people for
for a large portion of my life and uh
there's a lot of people who argue with
me in chat or like an email and being
like you don't understand you know like
you know soldiers they'll do the right
thing they're not robots and I'm like
they're not robots it's the bystander
effect though right people people
psychology is infectious nothing is is
more infectious than psychology and
people in groups it's the mob we've been
to we've been discussing the psychology
of the mob for as long as human beings
have been discussing psychology the
Stanford Prison Experiment for example
you put people in hierarchical
structures of power and then mob rule
takes over and then you go to base
Instinct that's what happens unless
you're very well trained but it when it
comes to the military it's actually
really simple to understand why this
this this uh E6 you said she's right
they would do this you know why it's
really really simple
if if if Ian is running through the
streets with a red bandana on or
whatever maybe he's jogging that's right
and then she's standing there and she
gets an order like that's the guy he's
the terrorists take him down take him
down you think she's gonna be like no I
don't know she shouldn't question that
order I mean she's going to be alive
about the military you're like if I
question the order are people gonna die
I mean we're talking about The Bourne
Identity right now right I guess the
third movie where he finally meets up
with the old guy and he's like is that
The Bourne Supremacy the prince yeah I
think or the born redundancy I think
it's really cool yeah right right I'm
not yeah but it came down to like you
got to shoot this guy why and the reason
was they wanted to break the person
right your individualism is gone you
thinking is gone you can we tell you to
kill and that's not how it works that's
not how we trained our people in 82nd
Airborne you we we put ourselves at
Great risk on a relatively uh regular
basis to not inflict harm on people
unnecessarily right
can't say the same about Obama right the
Drone strike stuff killed a lot of
innocent people I think something like
30 of the people killed no strikes were
just standing there one of the first
things he did was bombing a village of
women and children I've heard numbers
that collateral damage of drone strikes
are like they started enormously large
like 90 but they started just claiming
that oh it's a military age male they're
an enemy combatant just that's right
yeah anybody a military age male by the
way is a male 14 years old or older
right no so so I think people need to
understand this when you know when they
when they just reiterate to to a certain
extent if think about you yourself
standing around with your friends you
hear you hear a report like antifa's
coming in they're armed they got
handguns you see what just happened in
Portland where they were shooting at the
proud boys
randomly like this was on like there was
no reason okay so they they were they
were retreating the proud boys like were
walking forward and they had like you
know clubs and shields or whatever
probably not a good idea regardless this
guy turns around with a gun and starts
randomly just firing and hits one of the
guy eyes in in in the legs now imagine
you hear that and then all of a sudden
you see a dude with you know what looks
like a weapon and he's wearing all black
and then he's running towards you and
and then and they're like that's him
that's him stop and stop him
are you gonna be like
it's not even just from your leadership
the Panic can happen in those situations
uh uh under any normal or any any number
of circumstances so this is we're
talking about the the one of the
founding moments of our Republic here
the reason that John Adams ended up
getting involved with the Continental
Congress and the movement towards uh uh
uh becoming America right and breaking
off for the British Empires because
there were British soldiers
in Boston and they were guarding some
areas there was a protest by the Sons of
Liberty which was run by his cousin Sam
Adams right not not the beer guy or
maybe
I don't know
um he was he was a politician but
Sam Adams is doing this thing somebody
behind the British soldiers uh well
first of all people are throwing heavy
objects and hit one of the kids in the
head and then somebody behind them
yelled fire yep right finally through
the trial they figured out and John
Adams represented the British people
yeah and he felt they got a good trial
they did they got off and then still the
crown sent over and edict saying all
military Court martials will now be
tried back in England
so he's like well you don't even believe
in our ability to self-govern now I'm
going to get involved and he became the
second president United States so this
stuff can happen in any kind of power
vacuum it doesn't matter if it's a
leader doing it or if it's just the fog
of War you know what I mean imagine what
the fog of War looks like in modern day
when it's brother on brother right you
know what I mean yeah I think it's
important to realize that it's not evil
when you know this like a lot of people
are criticizing this young woman over
saying it and you know I'm I was I
didn't really want to do a big segment
on that because I'm like I don't know
what the full context is I don't know
it's like a five ten second clip or
whatever who knows what she's talking
about it was jump Cuddy and I'm like
that's not much I can add to that you
know if she's if there was like a 10
minute thing she was talking about or
there are other videos where she was
explaining why this subject came up
maybe there'd be more to criticize right
but I think you need to you need to
realize you're surrounded by your
buddies people you know people you trust
people who are there to protect you and
that's you that's your group you're not
going to sit around and wait to find out
when when you're dealing with a conflict
situation I I've been in I've been in
complex situations and I don't sit back
and be like well hold on maybe this guy
in the antifa thing who was threatening
us might not be antifa no we leave we
get out now if you're act if you're
there actively trying to suppress or
prevent violence and then you see
someone you're not just going to assume
well let's just call me talk to this guy
no this is why when I whenever I've been
arrested like legit arrested by cops
while covering things I've always been
released without being processed like
charges never occur or anything like
that because when I when I was in DC on
j20 in 2017 when Trump was being
inaugurated they surrounded everybody I
got trapped in this group it was a bunch
of antifa types
I stood off to the side and I I talked
to the cop like the cops that were
standing there with their batons out
guarding everybody I was like Hey I Just
Wanna let you know I'm a journalist and
they were like don't care then I'm like
is there a supervisor and then they're
like some guy behind us like I'll get a
supervisor and I told the supervisor
like hey why don't you know I'm a
journalist and he was like doesn't
matter you're all under arrest and I was
like just just letting you know when I
was talking to the cop
who was standing next to me because he's
guarding this group I'd be like officer
I'm going to place my bag down and I'm
going to be putting my shirt away and
taking my phone out just so you know and
then he would like not a little bit and
then I would unzip it slowly I'd open it
wide pull out my phone put my shirt in
because he doesn't know who I am he's
not going to sit here pretending he
knows that I'm not antifa or whatever or
violent right that's a good they're
pulling out a club it's a very good
point why not in that scenario uh just
be
for the for the person who might be on
the threatened end of that exchange am I
really going to let my politeness get me
killed does that seem like a trade-off
to you or could we as a society agree
that this is a messed up situation
neither one of us wanted it to come to
this but here it is so let's put your
hands up and back away slowly and then
we'll go in our separate directions or
whatever right I mean it seems like a
reasonable way to handle that but people
get super emotionally charged and look
I'm not and listen to that I get pissed
off as much as anybody else right yeah
probably more so I lash out all the time
I've been in fights with some of my
closest friends over nonsense like uh
Alex Jones is one of my closest friends
we talk all the time he actually just
sent me some cool videos of him shooting
the other day
um he went pretty hard after some of my
buddies
at Black Rifle I thought he was out of
line and I said some things that I
thought also were out of line like and
and the funny thing is a lot of people
on the internet talk about it still two
days after that we were sharing photos
uh from respective lakes that we were at
you know what I mean it wasn't never
really a rift between us but but it gets
perceived like that and it's it's
unfortunate that it can come to that
sometimes and I think it's because
things get so heated we start to
prioritize the wrong stuff I think I
think we need to understand that there's
different uh bubbles than Bubbles and
then bubbles right so we have the
largest bubble of like America well
technically I say the large bubble of
the world then you have like America
within the world right then you have the
different regions different states
different cities within that there's
different Power structures different
authorities you always have that Trope
of the of the cop investigating a murder
and the FBI guy walks in and goes we're
taking over jurisdiction yeah yeah the
feds are involved like uh Willem Dafoe
and Boondock Saints yeah that's who the
blank I am or whatever yeah yeah yeah
excellent excellent performance but so
when it comes to you know Communication
Breakdown when you have things moving so
quickly it's ultimately going to be like
the people around you is the Paramount
to be protected and sometimes there's
even Friendly Fire between different law
enforcement divisions or there's one
funny story where like the DEA and the
FBI like busted each other oh yeah
setting up like a drug thing that's so
fun I'm glad that happened that's
i i as a taxpayer I don't love the fact
that taxpayer money was wasted but I
guess if it was wasted on them with each
other and not busting some poor guy
that's just trying to get high to be
honest yeah leave him alone thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time